thanksgiving is less than a week away
and typically we'd be talking a lot
about holiday travel right now
but with the spike in case numbers the
cdc is warning against
it hector mejia is live this afternoon
from the welcome to las vegas sign with
the latest hi hector
hey there we've seen a steady stream of
visitors showing up here to take their
pictures
now whether massive crowds will travel
for the holidays or not
that is still up in the air this year
the lvcva is not even forecasting
visitation numbers for thanksgiving week
and the centers for disease control and
prevention is warning against
thanksgiving travel or gatherings
because of the skyrocketing coronavirus
numbers
more than one million new cases reported
in the country over the last week or so
one visitor here told me that not
everyone he's seen during his travels is
wearing a mask or following protocols
with people on the fence about traveling
aaa anticipates
a 10 percent drop in thanksgiving travel
nationwide
we are told that is the highest one-year
decrease
since the 2008 great recession
they're taking a wait-and-see approach
you know in many areas
restrictions and and things are changing
even here in nevada
with the governor asking residents to
stay home in california there's also a
travel advisory there
i came in on southwest airlines the
middle seats are all empty
they keep social dissident originally i
bought
was gonna buy tickets to the chiefs game
sunday night but they have no
fans but i still love my cheese
so i'm here to support go chiefs
here to watch you just watch the game
if you do choose to travel the cdc
recommends checking
restrictions before you go find out if
case numbers are high wherever it is
you're going
always wear a mask and stay at least six
feet apart
the cdc says staying home is the best
way to protect yourself
and others this year and for our
neighbors in california new restrictions
begin this weekend
they include governor gavin newsom's
order for non-essential places to close
by 10 pm
and also a curfew between the hours of
10 p.m
and 5 a.m for the 41 of the state's
58 counties reporting from the welcome
sign hector mejia
8 news now yeah that impacts most of
california all right hector thanks so
much for that